foreign
lights on it's 20 50. how does this
still not work
call my son
and turn down the damn lights
hi Mom
sweetie oh you look tired okay thanks
for calling are you busy not really just
finished studying good because I want to
tell you the story of how I met your
father I already know how you met dad ah
you know the basics but it's time for me
to tell you the unabridged version
kids I'm going to tell you an incredible
story the story of How I Met Your Mother
[Music]
Hannah
will you marry me
yeah
[Applause]
oh I can't believe I'm getting engaged
and seeing Beyonce
I can't believe I'm getting engaged
yeah
will you marry me you want to go out
sometime
I'm sorry
Carl's my boyfriend
what's up Carl
I promised Ted we wouldn't do that
do you know there's a Pop-Tart under
your fridge no but dibs
love your place thanks it was a total
score we got it from this old married
couple who posted it on the Wesleyan
alumni group even got him to leave their
swords
[Music]
associate produce buyer for Goliath
Market corporate office
I like to remember the uplifting words
of my favorite song
we will be on your side when you need a
friend through thick and thin you can
always depend on the world leaders and
credit and banking
Goliath National Bank
member FDIC Captain
permission to explain myself
Captain I know something happened
between you and Lily last night what no
nothing happened Captain's honor you can
ask my fiance fiance what fiance Captain
permission to clear things up granted me
we're engaged like I said I'm a mess too
well maybe we could be friends that are
messes instead of two messes who try to
date because that would just inevitably
be
a mess
it could be friends
[Music]